Republican lawmakers finally getting
their chance to grow former top Twitter
Executives who admitted they screwed up
by censoring the hunter Biden laptop
story
Twitter and other social media companies
took extraordinary steps
to suppress that story now mainstream
media Outlets have verified the laptop
but the damage has been done you
exercised an amazing amount of clout and
power over the entire American
electorate I think you guys got played
by the FBI and that's the scary part
but Democrats like AOC are dismissing
and calling questions about the hearing
silly does not even begin to capture
this Obsession what's more Twitter's
editorial decision has been analyzed and
debated Ad nauseam a whole hearing about
a 24-hour hiccup in a right-wing
political operation we're talking about
Hunter Biden's half fake laptop Story I
mean this is an embarrassment
Greg you were talking in the Green Room
about this story yes elaborate yes what
an interesting way to set this up yes
you know what I want to listen to the I
want to see every one of the f-51 Intel
agents I think that's going to be I want
to know how that was choreographed how
that was put together and and
the strategy here with these folks is to
admit that they screwed up because it
doesn't matter they won right they they
could say yeah you know we screwed up
you know we shouldn't have done that but
they're kind of at the same time
admitting they got away with it and they
can't arrest them you can't do anything
about it uh they you know they did
censor material I know that people say
private companies can't do that but when
the government colludes as part of a
cabal which they called it to vanish
actual news to affect an election that
is censorship and they weren't played by
the FBI uh they were they were playing
with the FBI
judge what question would you ask if you
were on a committee uh and of course you
may have been asked we haven't seen the
whole camera what would you ask of those
execs what I would ask is why they
didn't bother to try to uh confirm that
it was real uh by you know just finding
someone who had sent or received an
email all you have to do is say this is
typical you know investigative reporting
all you find out if you look at what the
emails are and say did you ever receive
an email from Hunter Biden did you ever
send an email to Hunter Biden that's the
end of it then you start realizing that
it's real but the thing that I find most
interesting is what Jim Jordan just said
you got played by the FBI they not only
got played by the FBI but I agree with
Greg I think that they played with the
FBI because they are very anti-uh
Republican they wanted Joe Biden to win
and we already know from the numbers
that but for the the suppression of this
uh laptop a lot of people might have
voted differently and I also think that
it's important to note that when you've
got an FBI that is reaching out to
social media companies and saying be on
the lookout for a elite Russian
disinformation on a laptop and then
you've got the FBI lying into a fisa
court and then you've got you know all
kinds of agencies getting involved like
even with the balloon saying we didn't
tell the president for a bunch of days
you start to wonder who's running the
country is the president running the
country or are these agencies running
the country Dana you have that question
too well I would ask this I mean what is
the Democrat strategy because if Twitter
is there and saying yeah you know what
you're right we're caught you caught us
then why are the Democrats then all
saying that this hearing is baloney the
hearing just accomplished what they set
out to do and I also here's my question
where is Jack Dorsey how does he get
away with not having to come and testify
he was the CEO he was the leader and all
of us only these guys have to come and
the other thing is that AOC may have
missed it last week but even Hunter's
lawyers are saying that that is his
laptop not even half half laptop oh slap
prime time yeah so big business
conspired with the FBI to pick a
president and AOC doesn't care
she'd rather talk about all these other
things well she was at the oversight
committee for the last two years she
didn't haul in any CEO any Titan of
industry and grilled them she didn't do
anything and why is AOC taking Hunter's
side that's who she wants to throw down
with Hunter Biden who's dropping n-words
all on the laptop sexually harassing his
assistants the Silver Spoon corrupts
guys dragon is you know what all over
the place taking everyone's cash she
loves a bad boy Jesse I mean she really
does
how much though she is engaged listen I
I wouldn't I wouldn't take sides with
that guy goes against everything she
stands for it's all about ideology the
left the left bunch of losers right
judge I wanna Brian kill Mead I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now